run away judges versus the Trump agenda
that's the focus of tonight's angle
today its CPAC the president rallied the
conservative faithful and urge them not
to let up as the midterm elections
approach don't be complacent okay don't
be complacent because if they get in
they will repeal your tax cuts they will
put judges in that you wouldn't believe
they'll take away your second Amendment
which we will never allow to happen
judges matter let's take gun legislation
now even if the president and the
Republican Congress are successful in
pressing his agenda life tenured judges
with radical outlooks can do it all that
applies to a whole host of issues this
is why it's so critical for president
Trump to nominate and see confirmed as
many judges as possible on both the
district courts and the appellate courts
now since Trump took office check this
out
major initiatives have been stalled or
stopped altogether by the courts
including his travel ban on some
majority Muslim countries his plans to
withhold federal funds from those
sanctuary cities his plan to rescind the
daca program and just yesterday his plan
to end Obama era oil and gas emission
regs and let's not forget the ban on
transgender people in the military
serving in the military so during just
his first nine months in office cities
or states filed 24 lawsuits against the
president according to Reuters Obama was
not subjected to similar lawsuits during
the same time period now a few weeks ago
New York District Court Judge Nicholas
Gore office
he was the Clinton appointee blocked
President Trump's decision to end
Obama's daca program he's the second
federal judge to do so now judge nikkor
office is an interesting character when
the daca case landed on his bench last
year he reacted like an MSNBC pundit he
claimed that the president's ending the
a program was called arbitrary and
capricious gracias
judge luis Gutierrez this judge has a
history of editorializing from the bench
and of course it ends up being like
legislating from the bench Americans
didn't elect judge Gore office to change
our immigration policy certainly not the
authority of the executive to enact
sensible immigration regulations he was
appointed to be a check on other
branches of government not a replacement
for them so if judge graphic office
wants to get into legislating he should
take off his long black robes pound the
pavement and then run for office and by
the way this isn't the first time that
that judge crossed the line from
impartial jurist to policy maker in 2012
he imposed racial quotas on the New York
City Fire Department as a way to address
the complaints from minorities who
failed the department's entrance exams
now declaring the fire department a
quote bastion of white male privilege
judge Gore office required the
department to hire two black
firefighters and one Hispanic for every
five hired now parts of his ruling were
later vacated by the appeals court that
questioned his impartiality they barred
him from presiding over future trials
related to the case that's how bad it
was sadly no one barred him from ruling
on the daca program and frankly he
should have recused himself because his
liberal bias was that obvious
Graff is sat on the bench and repeatedly
slammed the president for his quote
recurring redundant drumbeat of
anti-latino commentary recurring
redundant drumbeat isn't that whole
thing we're done dude oh my gosh it's
just bad writing come on judge go office
was blatant in his disdain for the
president and his policies then the
Chief Judge of the Fourth Circuit Court
of Appeals Roger Gregory wrote the
majority opinion blocking the
travel ban now it's a different circuit
now it's the second time the fourth
circuit has pulled this routine this
time Judge Gregory a George W Bush
appointee believe it or not claims that
the president's travel restriction on
six largely Muslim countries is
unconstitutionally tainted with an
animus toward Islam for two hundred and
eighty five unbelievably twisted pages
the ruling tries to turn Trump's
campaign rhetoric into a legal argument
ribéry writes that the travel ban drips
with religious intolerance animus and
discrimination sounds like he's talking
about his own opinion they say the ban
is an attempt to establish a national
religion that excludes Muslims that's
what the Fourth Circuit ruled well we're
gonna see how that reasoning holds up at
the Supreme Court which by the way has
just announced that it's going to review
these travel ban decisions on April 25th
political grandstanding by Juris the
type that we just talked about whether
it's from the bench or in public forums
they saw what judge Justice Ginsburg
said the other day about the bullying
during the election Hillary and the
sexism all of that ends up undermining
confidence in the courts and it
certainly compromises our view of an
impartial judiciary and that goes as I
said for the notorious RBG Ginsburg as
well the left wants to do through the
courts what they couldn't achieve at the
ballot box it's so transparent to me now
Obama certainly knew this game he was
able to stack the federal bench with 334
judges
Clinton appointed 387 judges in
President Trump well he understands the
threat posed by an activist judiciary
the president has had to deal with
activist judges working against him ever
since he took office I'll be criticized
by them
for speaking harshly about our courts
this new order was tailored to the
dictates of the ninth circuit's in my
opinion flawed ruling this is the
opinion of many an unprecedented
judicial overreach now there are
currently 147 vacancies on the federal
courts 122 in the district courts in 17
at that important appellate level Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell did a
fantastic job in 2017 getting Trump
nominees confirmed a record 12 appeals
court judges now Obama only got 3 in his
first year so that's really good
nevertheless a lot of work remains to be
done the only way to counter the
excesses of life tenured judges like
gore office is for Trump to fill the
bench with his own juris men and women
who stay within their constitutional
boundaries meanwhile we'll continue on
this show to expose the arbitrary and
capricious rulings of judges who
frustrate the public will and exceed
their article 3 authority and that's the
angle